بين هذه الصور وهذه نصر وهزيمه وشكان لم
يبث فيها بعد من الغالب ومن المغلوب لكن
الحديث اليوم عن تضاؤل فرص المقاومين
الاوكرانيين في
المعركه في المدينه منذ اغسطس الماضي
ووفقا لاخر المعلومات تبدو قريبه
بالنهايتها نهايه لا يريد كلا المتحاربين
الخروج منها مهزومه
سيناريوهان ثالث لهما امام كييف في باغموت
اما الانسحاب خلصت بعد تدمير الجسور
والطرق لكسب الوقت وابطاء القوات الروسيه
ومنعها من التوجه غربا في العمق الاوكراني
او الانتظار حتى الاستسلام لكن هذا الخيار
قد ينتهي بكارثه عسكريه بالنسبه الى
القوات المدافعه عن المدينه
بالمقابل تعمل روسيا على قطع الامدادات عن
القوات الاوكرانيه في قلب المدينه وضرب
طوق كامل حولها المقاومه الاوكرانيه
المستمره منذ ثمانيه اشهر استنزفت الكثير
من قدرات القوات المهاجمه حيث تسعى
لانسحاب محكم وبشروط هي من يسوعها على ارض
المعركه
خلال الهجوم يتقدمون في مجموعات من خمسه
او عشرين عنصرا نحن نبدو لقصار جهدنا
لضربهم هناك الكثير منهم ماتوا وجثثهم
منتشره في جميع انحاء الميدان بين ترقب
للنصر وهزيم في باخموت قد تكون الساعات
القادمه حبلى بالمفاجات مفاجات قد تاتي
بانتصار رمزي انتظرته موسكو طويلا وهزيمه
لا تريدها وان كانت بطعم النصر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]